What if coronavirus could be prevented with a pill?
Pfizer said it has started testing an oral antiviral drug...
...for people exposed to COVID.
In a mid to late stage study,...
...Pfizer will test the pill in up to 2,660 healthy adults aged 18 or older.
Participants in the trial must live in the same household...
...as a person with a confirmed case of coronavirus.
The antiviral pill is designed to block the activity of a key enzyme...
...needed for the coronavirus to multiply.
Pfizer and its rivals including US-based Merck,...
...have been racing to develop an easy to administer pill for COVID-19.
To date, Gilead Sciences' intravenous drug Remdesivir...
...is the only approved antiviral medicine for COVID-19 in the US.
And while effective, it is time-consuming, costly...
...and requires medical assistance to administer the treatment.